anthony blinken 58 ans il pas un nouveau
venu sur la scène diplomatique
depuis 2002 il est l'homme de confiance
de celui qui deviendra officiellement le
46e président des états unis le 20
janvier prochain
pas si mal pour quelqu'un qui ne savait
pas trop quoi faire dans sa jeunesse
conseiller à la commission des affaires
étrangères du sénat puis conseiller à la
sécurité nationale sous obama en 2008
anthony blinken a donc fait son chemin
mécanisme price en mai 2011 il apparaît
sur cette célèbre photo prise dans le
bunker de la maison blanche alors que le
président obama hillary clinton et joe
biden assistent en direct à la capture
de ben laden au pakistan
anthony blinken et là en retrait à
suspense incroyable
nous étions sur le dossier pendant des
mois ouais on se crée personne ne le
savait il deviendra quatre ans plus tard
le numéro deux du département d'état
jusqu'au jour où donald trump devient
président
déménager à paris à l'âge de 9 ans avec
sa mère et son beau père samuel bizarre
un rescapé d'auschwitz célèbre avocat et
ancien conseiller de kennedy blinken y
apprendra la langue de molière
ces décisions unilatérales de mettre
notre ambassade des états unis à
jérusalem a évidemment provoqué cet
affrontement américain juif new yorkais
parisien ses multiples facettes annonce
aussi le retour du multilatéralisme de
la part des états unis
retour à la table de l'om est ce plus
grand respect des nations unies probable
retour de l'accord sur le nucléaire avec
l'iran
bref la fin du america first de donald
trump qui a contribué véritable repli
sur soi des américains mais aussi à des
antagonismes avec les alliés habituels
des états unis je pense que c'est une
vision totalement différente du monde et
du rôle des etats-unis dans le monde
la tâche de reconstruire ses liens et
évidemment ce colossal
après les différents secrétaires d'état
de la présidence troll l'ambiance est
donc au changement de doctrine et
probablement aussi au changement de
rythme diplomatique à la maison blanche
pour un homme qui pousse de temps en
temps la chansonnette avec son groupe
musical
[Musique]
et qui n'hésite pas non plus à
vulgariser les grandes institutions
internationales
un nouveau souffle donc puisque après un
passage à vide politique des quatre
dernières années
le voici donc propulsé numéro un de la
diplomatie américaine
ici frédéric arnold radio canada
montréal